good morning miss Montano I'm here with
your breakfast expression this room up
mafia 3 the long end development sequel
to mafia 2 takes players to the
dangerous criminal underworld of new
Bordeaux a city based on New Orleans set
in 1968 it tells the story of Lincoln
clay a young biracial Vietnam veteran
who returns home to find the only family
he ever had and his city in shambles
armed with unfailing charisma and a
burning desire for a revenge
Lincoln sets out to take down the Mafia
dismantling it arm by arm in an effort
to make it all his own watch stab Ellis
in the gut I couldn't do nothing about
it then but I sure as hell can now what
is immediately apparent about mafia 3 is
that it takes its time world building
mafia 3 opens up on protagonist Lincoln
Clay detailing his background family
life and the circumstances of his turn
to crime the game details relationships
with lengthy cutscenes and several
missions in which these people work
together when Lincoln does finally go
off the rails his vow a revenge feels
real and justified thanks to the time
spent in the narrative building up the
plot at this stage in Lincoln's story
mafia 3 really opens up missions can be
completed in any order and in a variety
of different ways each has its own long
list of objectives to complete but you
don't necessarily have to tick off every
box you can pick and choose these
objectives to complete in any order and
sometimes succeeding at only a handful
will open up the way to the final task
often a boss fight with a major
character taking down this notorious
criminal means completing the mission
and you won't have the opportunity to go
back and complete the rest of the
smaller objectives for someone who wants
to 100% the game there's a lot to tackle
however if you're a more reserved player
don't worry you'll be able to whittle
down that to do
after only a few hits if you tend to go
straight for higher value targets
Hey look cool it I don't want no trouble
trouble ain't no trouble here during my
hands-on time with a recent demo I spent
some time tracking down a target through
the Bayou and also busting up a
prostitution ring both missions had
their own unique objectives and brought
me into the line of fire with very
different people the places to in which
I fought my battles were entertaining
and how buried in coop they were one
took place on a sinking riverboat in the
dark depths of the bayou and another
brought me into the fancier part of town
busting trapped girls out of seedy hotel
rooms these environments add two new
Bordeaux's personality and after
checking out a few I got the sense of
just how big and shady mafia three's
setting really is but while mafia
three's new Bordeaux is very similar to
New Orleans it's not quite an exact copy
the studio didn't want to lifts New
Orleans wholesale because they wanted to
keep the mafia series in fictional
cities the city of New Orleans is very
flat and there's not a lot of elevation
which means creating an entertaining
driving system would be challenging and
also a bit boring so new Bordeaux
differs from its real-world counterpart
in this with more beautiful vistas
cresting hills and less one-way streets
packed with parked cars driving felt
fluid and I enjoyed spending time in my
car listening to the radio and taking in
the sights of the city on my way to the
next hit
the other excellent thing about mafia
threes rapper is its soundtrack it's
thrilling to hear paint it black or I
fought the law as you flee the scene or
get a chance to play with the radio as
you drive through town in the dead of
night the soundtrack made up of songs
from the 1960s adds a strong sense of
time and place to mafia 3 we only have a
few short weeks left before mafia 3 hits
store shelves what are you most looking
forward to in mafia 3 let us know in the
comments and stay tuned to games.com for
more mafia news you can prey on the way
up
you